this video is sponsored by morningbrew
use the link in the description to sign
up for their completely free
daily newsletter and stay up to date on
all things business
tech and finance on december 27
1967 amara alto was born at 4 45
a.m she was born perfectly healthy to a
married couple
hugh and leanne alto as amara peered out
into the world for the first time
her parents look back down at her in awe
a collection of matter
atomic nuclei building and decaying into
a physical
observable person in the world for the
first time
just two years after giving birth to
amara by a stroke of unbelievably good
fortune
amara's mother leanne sold a majority
stake of a business she had been
building over the prior several years
the business had not yet become
profitable but leanne had just recently
filed and been granted two utility
patents on her
products that suddenly became highly
valuable to the company offering the
acquisition deal
leanne took the deal maintained an
executive role in large stock in the
company
and her and hugh became exceptionally
wealthy
their net worth skyrocketing into the
nine figures over the following years
throughout her life amara would be
contained deeply inside the shelter of
this wealth
her parents being able to pull almost
any strings and provide just about
anything for her
throughout her life amara would try a
variety of so-called passions and
interests and careers
never really feeling much urgency or
risk or responsibility
in her adult years she would end up
primarily working for her mother's
company
she didn't really do much of anything
though and was sort of always treated as
the founder's daughter
which she never really had the
motivation to change
amara would marry a man whom her mother
introduced her to at a high status
business gala
she would go on to have four children
with him inherit and build a large
wealth
and she and her husband would inject the
same fortune disguised problems
that they had growing up into their
children the family's glue made almost
entirely of money
and social appearance likewise this was
the case for most of amara's friend
groups as well
throughout her life despite appearances
she was
generally miserable when she was 40
amara and her husband divorced for a
myriad of good reasons
amara would grow old and die never
remarrying
living a financially luxurious life that
she never really had to touch
and so she never really did on january
3rd
1968 amara alto was born
at 1201 am she was born about a week
later than expected
but perfectly healthy to a married
couple hugh and leanne alto
as amara peered out into the world for
the first time her parents looked back
down at her
a collection of matter atomic nuclei
building and decaying
into a physical observable person in the
world for the first time
just three months after the birth of
amara in a stroke of terrible misfortune
and bad timing
after feeling under the weather and
sleeping through an extremely important
meeting
that he was supposed to lead amara's
father hugh
was fired from his job following being
fired he struggled to find work for
quite some time
and amara's mother leanne who was trying
to get a business off the ground and
into the black was forced to divert her
attention away from the business
and join q in trying to find a job with
benefits during this volatile time
of amara's infancy leanne was able to
find one while
hugh reoriented his career but she
essentially had to let her business die
in the process
as time went on leanne and hugh would
restabilize themselves
both working relatively average
full-time office jobs
making enough money to live relatively
average comfortable lives
they had to keep a somewhat close eye on
their spending but always managed to
stay out of any further financial
trouble
when amara was 11 she decided she wanted
to start playing soccer
because the age cut off for the
different soccer leagues was january 1st
she was the oldest on her team because
she was the oldest
at an age where months often looked like
years she was also one of the best
because she was one of the best she
received more coaching and playing time
and because she received more focus and
time she got better
and better this effect further
compounding throughout her teens
in her adolescence she worked part-time
jobs in order to have her own spending
money
and afford soccer camps and top of the
line soccer equipment
developing strong self-discipline and
perseverance along the way
at 22 she was selected for the united
states
woman's national soccer team which she
would play on
for a long and fruitful career in her
thirties
she met a man whom she fell deeply in
love with married and had three children
she enjoyed and took great pride in her
career family and life
feeling a great sense of responsibility
for her successes
she would grow old and die having lived
a life that she found completely rich
and meaningful on december 27th 1967
at 4 45 am hugh alto is asleep
lee ann kim is also asleep the next day
he wakes up goes to work and then
returns home to his apartment in the
city
that same day leanne does the same
returning to her small home
in the suburbs outside the city eight
years prior
on june 12th 1959 hugh got sick from
some food he ate
and was bedridden for nearly the entire
weekend
that weekend leanne happened to be
hanging out with some friends
she rarely saw who also happened to have
some mutual friends
with hugh hugh's friends and leanne and
her friends hung out that saturday
while hugh watched tv at home
on december 27 1967 isaac alto
was born at 2 17 am he was born
perfectly healthy to a married couple
hugh and leanne alto nine months prior
while eating at a restaurant
hugh and leanne's waiter accidentally
mixed up hugh's plate
with a plate for a table just two over
from them it took about eight seconds
for hue to notice and notify the waiter
who then took another 16 seconds to
realize what had happened
and correct the mix-up this then led to
a couple other short delays while paying
and getting through various stoplights
on the drive home
once hugh and leanne got home they got
into bed
isaac was conceived that night he was an
only child
on december 27 1967 amara
alto was born at 4 45 am she was born
perfectly healthy to a married couple
hugh and leanne alto following amara's
birth
hugh and leanne's life would run fairly
smoothly both working their careers with
no major successes
but no major setbacks either at age 39
however
a single cell inside leanne's body began
uncontrollably growing
and dividing this one cell turned into
millions and millions of other abnormal
cells that continue to grow
and divide relentlessly amara would be
just 12 years old when she lost her
mother
to cancer the treatments and efforts
towards trying to save leanne
ate through all their savings and left
hugh filing for bankruptcy
he never really recovered and struggled
through relative poverty and mental
instability
for the remainder of his life he and
amara moved to a small apartment in a
lower income neighborhood when amara was
14
which placed her in a new school system
and exposed her to an entirely different
life
amara would struggle with various
substance abuse throughout most of her
life
starting around this time she married a
man who shared such a lifestyle
after having two children with him she
worked as a bartender in small local
bars for her entire life
always loathing herself and her
continuous inability to make something
of her life
feeling a deep responsibility for her
inadequacy
not having much money substance abuse
and mental instability
ran rampant through her marriage
friendships and life
until she died at the young age of 55.
on december 6 1967 amara alto was born
at 3 58 pm
to a married couple hugh and leanne alto
she was not born perfectly healthy
arriving more than two weeks early she
was born prematurely
and her body was still exceptionally
fragile and many of her organs were
still
underdeveloped the doctor suggested that
there was a chance amara would fully
recover
but also a chance that the premature
birth could lead to some mild to
moderate developmental issues
[Music]
leanne and hugh would go on to live a
nice financially comfortable life
nothing extreme happening in any
direction at around eight years old
however
amara began experiencing her parents
fear and she was soon classified as
learning disabled
diagnosed with dyslexia dysgraphia and
processing impairment
the older amara got the more she began
to notice and understand the
implications
of why she was always treated
differently in school she realized
people thought she was dumb
and the more the school system seemed to
press down on her tell her she wasn't
working hard enough was a bad or
distracting student
or even ridiculed her amara found it
hard not to believe
that she was as she aged through middle
school and high school though
she began feeling an increasing drive to
prove everyone wrong
this mission caused amara to put great
effort into learning new ways of
learning
developing methods of managing her mind
and modifying and adapting the angles
from which she approached ideas and
problems
slowly she began to successfully push
back
following high school despite all odds
as a result of her phenomenal act scores
impressive grade improvement and
unbelievably moving application essay
amara was accepted to her first choice
school university of michigan
ann arbor where she would enroll in
their top-tier undergraduate physics
program
as an effective her need to overcome her
immense learning tribulations
she had by now found highly creative
ways of reimagining problems and
solutions
seeing and approaching math equations
and theories in profoundly unique and
effective ways
she would not only catch up to the
standards of her age but quickly
surpassed them following her
undergraduate degree
she would go on to earn her phd in
physics at harvard
by her 40s amara had become a
well-respected theoretical physicist
specializing in quantum mechanics
gravity and cosmology
she became a research professor at
massachusetts institute of technology
wrote and published several popular
books and often appeared on various
media programs as well as science events
where she would give talks interviews
and lectures
at age 46 amara was giving a talk at a
science festival
for a slightly more introductory level
audience
after briefly introducing herself and
the topics she would be covering
amara said to the audience you know my
whole childhood
i was told in all sorts of different
ways how dumb i was
and for a while i believed it the world
sets these constraints
lays forth systems and ways of
considering ideas and people
filtering out the world and its talent
according to standards and methods
my life and work have taught me many
things but perhaps one of the most
important things
is how much is not what it seems or what
you expect
how much is fragmented from what we
accept as true
rational or rightfully status quo sean
carroll recently said
if the world is truly quantum mechanical
we should change our view
of what is obvious and what is
surprising
my focus over the last several years as
some of you may know
has been researching and interpreting
the wave function and its measurement in
quantum mechanics
i am as some of you probably also know a
very vocal proponent of a theory known
as the many worlds interpretation
and there aren't many other contemporary
theories that require such a
relinquishment of your intuitions as
this one
for those of you who don't know the many
worlds interpretation
basically argues that an essential
function in quantum mechanics known as
the wave function
is objectively real and the strange
randomness of a particle superposition
or indeterminate state coming into an
inexplicable definitive state when it is
measured
as explained by the fact that all
possible outcomes of the measurement
are actually physically realized into
other worlds
or universes that split at the moment of
the particle interacting
or becoming entangled with some
component of its environment
in this case a measurer in other words
basically every time a quantum system
becomes entangled with its environment
and decoheres the world splits off into
different parallel worlds with
it and so each time we ourselves
become entangled with one of these
systems decohering
which are constantly happening inside of
us every second atomic nuclei building
and decaying in our bodies
and interacting with the observable
environment a new
different version of us goes with it
into a different world
we of course never know or experience
this for the potentially infinite worlds
and their differing outcomes and
possibilities
are always experienced by us in any
version
as one one single possible way
but there are potentially near infinite
other ways
other what ifs asked and answered
differently not only
possible but very real happening in
parallel
and so i also believe that it is more
than likely that there are many many
other different amaras
existing right now i will never know how
things could have gone or are going for
any of them
but i do know this each one of us has a
world with conditions
and each one of us has their own
conditions within that world
some work out some don't but you can
almost never know which it's going to be
and why our advantages sometimes turn
out
to be our disadvantages and our
disadvantages
sometimes turn out to be our advantages
my so-called learning disability the
thing i dreaded for the entire first
half of my life
was not an obstacle that i had to
overcome it is precisely the reason
why i am up here life is a game of
arbitrary odds
whatever success we have or don't
whatever person we become or don't
the reasons for everything are concealed
within the odds
for most of my life it was as if i
existed in another world
that could not communicate with this one
now i teach about the likelihood
that this is actually true for us all
trust me the odds work in mysterious
ways
all right that's my little introductory
spiel now let's actually get into some
theory
[Music]
this video was sponsored by morningbrew
while it's both important and desirable
to stay informed in general
traditional corporate news is often
somehow both chaotic and boring
saturated with contrived stories and
drawn out into loud but tediously
repetitive information
this of course leaves many of us looking
for our news through other means like
social media
but with its cluttered chaos and often
untrustworthiness
this doesn't quite solve the problem
completely either
morningbrew is a free daily newsletter
that cuts through all the noise
by curating stories in business tech and
finance
consolidating the most relevant and
valuable news into succinct
enjoyable and often witty pieces that
get you up to speed every day
in as fast as just 5 minutes over the
past weeks
morning brew has made it easy to keep up
with new heads popping up in the world
of cryptocurrency
sharing both voices of support and
critique and exploring phenomena like
the fast-growing meme inspired
cryptocurrency
dogecoin if you're interested in using
morning brew
you can use the link in the description
below to sign up signup takes just 15
seconds
and is completely free and of course
thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video
[Music]
you